CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this segment, we're going
to talk about the product
rule for three
functions and then
we're going to do an example.
And what I want to do first
is remind you the product rule
for two functions,
because we're going
to use that to figure
out the product
rule for three functions.
So throughout this
segment, we are
going to assume that u and v
and w are all functions of x.
So I'm going to drop
the of x just so it's
a little easier to write.
This notation should
be familiar with things
you saw in the lecture.
So, for two functions,
let me remind you.
If u*v, the product, and
you take its derivative,
so prime will denote d/dx.
Then we can take the
derivative of the first times
the second function left
alone, plus the derivative
of the second function
times the first left alone.
So this should again
be familiar from class.
And now what we want
to do is expand that
to the product of three
functions, u times v times w.
And we're going to
explicitly use this rule.
So, u*v*w prime is what
we want to look at.
So we're just going
to take advantage
of what we know to figure out
what this expression will be.
What this product of
three functions when
I take its derivative will be.
So in order to do this
easily, what we're going to do
is treat v times w
as a single function.
OK?
So v times w will be our second
function that essentially takes
the place of the V up here.
So using the product
rule for two functions,
what I get when I
take this derivative,
is I get u prime times v*w plus,
I take the derivative of this
second thing,
which is v*w prime.
And then I leave u alone.
OK?
We're not quite done,
but you can see now,
again if we compare
to what's above,
you take the derivative
of the first function,
you leave the second
function alone.
You take the derivative
of the second function,
you leave the first
function alone.
But now again,
what do we do here?
Well we have a product rule for
two functions, so let's use it.
So, I'll leave the first
thing alone, u prime-- oops,
that does not look
like a v-- v*w plus,
now let's expand this.
Take the derivative of
the first function there.
That's v prime.
I leave the w alone.
Plus the derivative of
the second function.
That's w prime.
I leave the v alone.
And I keep the u there.
OK?
I'm going to just
expand and write it
in a nice order, so we can see
sort of exactly what happens.
So, u prime v*w plus v
prime u*w plus w prime u*v.
So what you can see
here is, what happens?
You take the derivative
of the first function,
you leave the second
and third alone.
Then you take the derivative
of the second function,
you leave the first
and third alone.
Then you take the derivative
of the third function,
you leave the first
and second alone.
And you add up
those three terms.
I would imagine that at this
point you anticipate a pattern.
So if I had a fourth function.
If I did u times v times
w times z, let's say.
And I took that derivative
with respect to x.
You could probably
anticipate, you
would have four terms
when you added them up.
And that fourth term would
have to include a derivative
of the fourth function.
So from here, actually
you can probably
tell me what the derivative of
the product of n functions is.
And you can check it using
the same kind of rule.
But what we're going
to do at this point,
is we're going to just make
sure we understand this.
We're going to
compute an example.
So since we know products--
or we know derivatives
of powers of x, and we know
derivatives of the basic trig
functions, we'll do a product
rule using those functions.
So, let me take an example.
So we'll say, f of x equals
x squared sine x cosine x.
OK?
And I want you to
find f prime of x.
OK, I'm going to give
you a moment to do it.
You should probably
pause the video here,
make sure you can do
it, and then you can,
you can restart the video when
you want to check your answer.
OK, so we have a product
rule for three functions,
we have an example that
I asked you to determine
and gave you a moment to do it.
So now I will actually work
out the example over here
to the right.
So I will determine
f prime of x.
Now what are our
three functions?
Well we have x squared
is the first, sine x
is the second, cosine
x is the third.
So we'll have three terms.
The first term has to have the
derivative of the x squared.
That's going to give me a 2x.
And I leave the other
two terms alone.
So I have 2x sine
x cosine x plus-- I
may want to just
write these below.
OK.
Now in the next
term, I should take
the derivative of the sine x.
And leave the x squared
and the cosine x alone.
The derivative of
sine x is cosine x.
So I'm actually going to
write this underneath.
So we'll have-- I'm going to put
the plus underneath also so we
remember it's a sum.
Plus, so the derivative
of sine x is cosine x.
And then we have a
times x squared times--
oops-- another cosine
x, the third function.
OK?
And then the third term,
I take the derivative
of the third function and I
leave the first and second
alone.
The derivative of cosine
x is negative sine x.
So I actually have a
negative sine x times x
squared times the sine x here.
I can do some
simplifying if I want.
But maybe, if I were
trying to write this nicely
for someone who was
reading mathematics,
I would put all of the
polynomials in front
and all of the
coefficients in front.
So to be very kind to someone,
I might write it like this.
And notice cosine x cosine
x is cosine squared x.
And then minus x
squared sine squared x.
And there are other
ways, I could rewrite
this and using trig identities.
But this is a sufficient
answer at this point.
So this is actually a good
way to write the derivative
of that function, f of x.
And this is where we'll stop.